We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2 1 9 2, David P..
We are trying to keep the voicemails non virus
focused.
Here is a voters saying she liked Bernie better,
but voted Biden because she does not believe
Bernie can win.
Take a look.
My name's Mary O'BRIEN.
I'm living in a large facility and I'm voting
for Biden.
I wanted to vote for Bernie, but I didn't
think he could win.
I like him better, but I want I want Trump
defeated.
Thank you.
So I am hearing this from a fair number of
people.
The latest polls suggest either that Biden
and Bernie are doing equally well against
Donald Trump in hypothetical matchups or that
Biden is doing a little better than Bernie.
But I'll tell you, with everything going on
with the virus, I believe that the polling
is going to be thrown completely out of whack.
Joe Biden, his press conferences about the
virus have not been great.
His interviews about the virus have not been
great.
Bernie's been doing livestreams and talking
about solutions.
I have no idea whether this will reopen the
window of opportunity for Bernie.
But there is one person explaining their vote
for Biden despite liking Bernie.
More tonight.
Chess tournament, 8:00 p.m. Eastern.
I'll be streaming it.
It'll be unleashed.
Prescott orig.
I invite you to join me.
Otherwise, I will speak to you on the bonus
show in mere minutes for tomorrow.
Back on the program.